well it would give me an opportunity to
cry at the beginning of every episode
every table read this is new last time
we're doing episode 12 Julie Bowen on
what it would mean to her for Modern
Family to get one more season it would
let us all like properly grieve and
celebrate the end of the season at the
series as opposed to it being like right
now and we're like no no this can't be
it says we're all enjoying everything no
one's crying no one's sad so we look
forward to being sacked et caught up
with the actress who's brought Claire
Dunphy to life for ten seasons at the
feeding America event in Los Angeles on
Saturday where she opened up about the
likelihood of the ABC show coming back
for one more season we were approached
the cast gave a gleeful yes but I think
that there's lots of behind the scenes
action that has to happen I think with
Fox and ABC buying Fox I think there's
some extra building worth of paperwork
it has to go through but I'm hoping it
does I really am so are we during the
mid-season finale we learned that
Claire's daughter hailey who's played by
Sarah Hyland is expecting a baby with
her boyfriend Dylan it's appropriate I
mean we've watched these kids grow up
it's kind of you know and at the end of
the end of the pilot was Elton John the
circle of life you know like it's
granted with a very funny twist but that
is we're doing the circle of life babies
making babies we just keep going
meanwhile the 28 year old actress
recently opened up about her own
real-life health struggles which include
a second kidney transplant dialysis and
suicidal thoughts she's she's a rock
star what can I say I mean do what her
body has gone through and if you've ever
met her I mean I'm not big and edgy next
to me is like a little slip of a thing
and and
then I don't even know how many
surgeries she's been through and she's a
tough little cookie and I know that
she's a survivor and she's a lovely
person as well I'm very proud of her I'm
very proud of all of my real and fake
children I really am
they've all turned out well Julie was
joined by two of her three real-life
children at the feeding America event
which is the nation's leading hunger
relief organization I thought it was
particularly appropriate as they've
gotten older they can participate more
and more and you know one in six kids
goes hungry in America every day and the
fact that I have three kids the math
should be that like 0.5 of my children
is hungry and they've never missed a
meal so I know how fortunate we are and
how important it is to give back
[Music]